this is the last conversation of this
type and it will be a conversation my
name is Bruce Shapiro I'm executive
director of the dart Center for
journalism and trauma at the Columbia
University Graduate School of Journalism
this is a project which supports
innovation in reporting on violence
conflict and tragedy around the world I
also teach investigative journalism and
it has been my great honor to visit
Russia and do some training with Russian
journalists on investigative reporting
and begin to know this community a
little bit the dart Center is one of the
co-sponsors of today's conference which
we are also deeply honored to do thank
you to Kathy and to Anya who have done
the lion's share of the work on this
thing this is a panel called the perils
and legacies of investigative journalism
for any of us who watch Russia or for
any of us who watch journalism one of
the inspiring and also at times
harrowing stories the last couple of
decades has been the rise of something
Russia had never before had genuine fact
based accountability journalism
reporting based not just on rumor and
conjecture but tracing down lines of
accountability for human rights abuses
in Chechnya lines of accountability for
abuses of the financial system for
corruption for political abuses of
various sorts investigative journalism
grew up out of nowhere thanks to
a growing generation of Russian
journalists who determined that they
wanted to develop this as a craft it's
not just a matter of investigative
journalism suddenly spring up full blown
when when official restrictions are
freedom the press go away investigative
journalism takes a while to evolve as
journalists learn a language as
journalists learn skills as journalists
develop and agenda and there's an
interplay between press freedom and the
evolution of investigative reporting
investigative reporting pushing outward
the boundaries of what's acceptable to
ask about what's acceptable to say press
freedom both restrictions on freedom of
the press pushing back and of course
informal threats and violence and
harassment pushing back at the same time
we've seen that a native Russian
investigative journalism has risen in
the years since perestroika we've also
seen something else courageous
non-russian correspondents who are
bringing all of the tools and techniques
and liberties of Western investigative
reporting to bear on the Russian state
we're going to have a wide-ranging
conversation today about all of these
issues about how press freedom
investigative reporting non Russian
journalists and Russian politics and law
all play together both over the last
couple of decades and particularly today
with russia at a critical moment in its
in its history i'm not going to do long
BIOS we are running late but i will say
that we're first of all oleg kashin from
commerce aunt is not going to be on this
panel Oleg will instead be on tomorrow
afternoon's pan
new Decembrists the digital revolution
but we are lucky today to be joined by
dunya me chava choose the press freedom
director of the OSCE Luke Harding of
Guardian and Nina odeon Olga Nova from
the Committee to Protect Journalists all
our friends allies people who've been in
conversation with one another for many
years and who probably don't agree about
everything so this will be an
interesting conversation what I'm going
to ask everyone to do on the panel to
speak for about 10 minutes or so but to
leave time for conversation both amongst
us and with all of you we're officially
supposed to run until five o'clock we
will run not much past that I will be a
a Puttanesca thorat area chair and try
to keep us to the schedule so with that
consumer warning in mine dunya why don't
you start out thank you very much Bruce
I'm honored to be here you said that we
will probably have disagreements when I
look at Nina and I look up I do not
think you will succeed in you know
having us doing different opinions about
this topic so i expect really from our
audience to try to trigger some
disagreements with just a group anyway I
see myself a bit as an alien in this
panel because I'm the only one actually
who is not a journalist I always wanted
to be one I tried but it was failure and
I wrote a lot about many issues related
to media freedom but I never considered
myself a journalist why I'm sharing this
with you because I think it's very much
connected to journalism to the
profession and to the topic we we have
today the noble and important role that
investigative journalism
have for our society something that in a
way I think we are losing not because
there is no not enough discussion in
relation to this topic not because
investigative journalism is something
that is not any more interested for many
countries we are losing it because
investigative journalists are more and
more attacked there is a i call it
unfortunately it's not very nice but i
do not and cannot find a better
description i call it a witch hunt
against these people it is something
that is visible it is something that all
my colleagues and here I'm talking about
NGOs that are working hard and you know
courageous people that are trying to
save people's life and to help all these
people that are in trouble not only
Russia but in many other countries but
in a way I see that we are all trying
extremely hard but in a way we are not
succeeding in order to change the
societies for better all of us I would
also like to share something which I
think it's extremely interesting it's
almost historical discovery I don't know
if you heard about this two days ago in
lamont they published declaration from
Albert Camus that was found in provence
by lamont researcher and it was written
I think 1939 ind evening republic on a
daily that he co-edited in a year when
he was living there and it is completely
related to journalism investigative
journalism I invite all of you to go and
see this declaration it is called the
four Commandments of free journals so if
we think of 93
9 what he actually said that lucidity
refusal irony and stubbornness is
something that the journalists that
needs and I think that's true in a way
no matter that we live in a digital age
and that we live in this new era and I
think this is absolutely timely for this
text to be discovered nowadays and to be
published by lamont I also notice that
english-speaking media did not pick up
this in a way on the 18th of March it
was published I will not go into details
but I will just read the start of it and
I think it's absolutely brilliant if we
think that he wrote it so long ago he
said it is difficult today to discuss
the press freedom without being accused
of extravagance accused of being Mata
Hari and to be convinced to be a nephew
of stallion so the same problems the
same issues that the journal is nowadays
are facing I can also ask the question
which is a question for all of us why's
this happening why the authoritarian
regimes are more and more afraid of
words more and more afraid of the
profession in general and why the global
attempt to protect free journalism is in
a way I would not say failing is under
threat because we are all very vocal
very public in my job what I'm trying to
do in relation to investigative
journalism I have direct access to the
government's so I also do not use only
public statements but also quiet
diplomacy because sometimes this is also
very important if a certain person's
life can be saved and i do not think
this is the role for one organization or
one institution it is a global joint
venture and
there is a common understanding among
journalists association and institutions
in order to help but in a way the the
another problem that I see is economic
problem that is very much present in the
countries that are also under auspices
of the OSC Central Asia Russia the
people are struggling with survival so
that that is one of the problems but I
also do see that no matter that we see
these problems people are still engaging
and writing and trying to investigate
the wrongdoings of the societies another
level of problems that I see in relation
to investigative journalism is enough
education and support in these countries
because in a way i will use an example
that I'm facing in most of the countries
with no democratic tradition I'm asked
together with my office to teach general
is how to do their job I refuse this
because I don't think we are school of
journalism journalists should learn
journalism in universities but also by
doing this job and there are more more
than enough institutions and schools
doing this but what is meant when a
master to to train journal is to be
professional the catch-22 here is they
ask these generous to be responsible and
the responsible responsibility is the
word that in a way I'm allergic to
because it's I connected with the
self-censorship what does it mean to be
responsible journalism in Central Asia
what does it mean to be responsible
journalism in the Balkans the part of
the world that I come from it means not
to be critical it means to write only
nice things on many occasions in some
Western countries i also heard
politicians saying why don't we have
good news
because good news are good for our
societies and that is also something
that is very much present when we
discuss issues of investigative
journalism so dear texts I would connect
it like that dear tax killings and in a
way the impunity that is so present and
it's you know constantly bringing more
and more chilling effect in so many
countries Russia of course is a you know
particular example and I do not think we
just discuss it before this panel I do
not think we are going to see light in
that area which is also going to reflect
everything that is happening in Central
Asia because of tradition and the way
this part of the world is organized so I
do not have any special formula I don't
have any solution to this but I'm also
very much aware that we need more and
more investigative journalists more and
more people that are courageous and that
need our help in order to continue their
important work they are doing it they
are continuing no matter if they were
beaten intimidated harassed there are
also ways of harassment that are in a
way very sophisticated so not just
killings not just attacks are bringing
chilling effect there are other means
and then we can also come to the point
of discussion or of psychological and
psychological trauma that your
organization is covering which in a way
is missing in many stories and in many
discussions when we talk about the
effect of intimidation of harassment in
the societies so i will dont hear
america and then thank you and we'll
have some conversation Thank You dunya
um Nina over CPJ you have a really
granular view of intimidation and
impunity journalist by journalist
beating by beating killing by killing
case by case whether in Russia or
anywhere else in the former Soviet Union
what talk a little bit about how you see
this landscape and in particular maybe
what you think has been changing why and
how in the last few years where it's all
going well since the the overall topic
of this conference is perestroika and
how the state of the media and press
freedom has changed from then until now
I'd like to give a little bit of a very
broad overview off of that and then talk
more in a little bit more specific terms
about the types of intimidation of
harassment of other kinds of attacks
that are used very creatively by
the Russian administration and the
enemies of press freedom in in the
former Soviet bloc and then I'd like to
alert all of us to what's coming because
the cold war may be over but there is a
lot of chilling there's a chilling
temperature in the air in Russia right
now it started 40 elections and the
protest movement and now we're seeing
the few the first examples of censorship
on certain selected media in Russia so
like for us all to be vigilant about
those signs and pick up on them early on
so we can react and be proactive instead
of reactive to the attacks that dunya
and justice describe briefly so
perestroika as it was intended was never
meant to fundamentally change it was
actually meant only to reformat the
existing Soviet system and glasnost was
to provide freedom of expression but
within limits and then the turbulent 90s
and the Soviet leaders understood they
witnessed how reformatting a dying
system was actually not a viable option
so despite us despite its limitations
the glasnost eroded the party controls
in the media and as the Soviet Union
fell apart while the new rules of
political of Social of economic conduct
were being established freedom of the
press found a window of possibility and
it used it papers were being set up they
started to conduct journalistic
investigations to shed light on crimes
past and present to illuminate
corruption high-level wrongdoing Human
Rights value
unravel social injustice is a new crop
of a journalist emerged a new crop of
broadcasters notably in TV and a home a
screen radio emerged a new breed of
reporters who defied the propaganda
rules of the the Soviet era who engaged
in original in critical and enterprising
coverage of events suddenly took to the
front lines and journalism for a while
became a very coveted and respected
profession unlike their Soviet
predecessors those new kind of
journalists asked tough questions and
reported life and the audience which was
voracious for that kind of general
information tuned in unfortunately so
did the authorities they witnessed the
impact that mass media and particularly
television could have on public opinion
it was NTV after all that overturned
overwhelmingly public opinion against
the first Chechen war by showing the
realities of Abbott life and it was also
an TV that helped reelect President
Boris Yeltsin in 1996 when he devoted
overwhelmingly positive coverage to him
while smearing his main rival well
auntie would entities help Yeltsin whose
popularity had plunged because of the
war ended up winning the vote but this
successful campaign in fact spelled out
the beginning of the end of NTV as an
independent voice when entities
management refused to play along and
when it was contracted to paint a public
image of yeltsin's chosen successor
vladimir putin that was favorable it
lost the game Putin took notice and four
days after his inauguration inmate
two thousand armed agents raided in TVs
owner and under the pretext of checking
for financial irregularities and entity
was never the same in fact in the decade
from 2000 until the present time entity
completely transformed from the
independent company that showed the
reality of violence and human rights
valuations and the Chechen war to the to
the tool that now just days ago aired a
Kremlin a Kremlin propaganda documentary
about which portrayed Russia's new
protest movement as an authentic and and
basically paid for by the West while the
NTV hostile takeover was a blatant and
unapologetic example of government
censorship Russian authorities between
2000 and now have been ever creative in
more ever more creative in their tactics
of discouraging enterprise journalism
those tactics have varied in type and
sophistication and they are airbrushing
critical charismatic voices from the
public space pushing disobedient critics
and persistent investigative journalists
to press out of limited audience where
they can have only limited influence to
launching politically motivated
prosecutions tax audits legal searches
against journalists and newsrooms
selected for retaliation to failing to
investigate murders and physical attacks
against the press as a rule in Russia
attacks the fall enterprising journalist
who asked tough questions and expose
inconvenient truths an international
journalists are not an exception those
who cover sensitive domestic issues for
global audiences have been the target
for censorship CPJ has documented at
least five cases in the past five years
including that of Luke Harding who is
now on this panel where Russia has
barked foreign journalists from working
in the country the ultimate form of
self-censorship however is that by the
bullet Russia has consistently been on
CPJ's impunity index a list of countries
worldwide where journalists are
regularly murdered for their work and
their murders remain unsolved this two
thousand or under the current
administration 20 journalists were slain
in retaliation for the reporting and in
only two cases were their killers
convicted in none of the cases have
those who commissioned the crimes those
who who sent those assassins to the
journalists doorsteps in none of those
cases they ever stood trial such record
of impunity is the greatest deterrent to
investigative journalism and the biggest
breeder of self-censorship amount press
workers until the killers and their
attackers of our colleagues are behind
bars enemies of the press will continue
to feel emboldened to practice
censorship by thuggery looking back the
NTV takeover of 2000 was a very telling
act it was a harbinger of what was to be
fold the media failed to fall into line
under Putin's Russia the brief thaw for
the media during the middle age of time
in office had positive effect in the way
in the sense that it allowed for
independent new platforms to emerge new
media projects such as the internet
channel dasht for example is as a good
is
is a good illustration of that they use
the rise in the use of social media
including Facebook and Twitter and the
Russian counterpart of Facebook
contacted for example once went up
during mid Vedas time in office mid
vidiyum medvedev was a blogger himself
and he also gave interviews to such
media outlets as nova gazeta and gazeta
are you and these gestures whether they
were genuine whether they were part of a
pre-planned of a pre-planned formula to
appease the critics of press freedom
conditions in Russia they are those
gestures marked a change in the Kremlin
tone which was welcome but now with
Putin's coming back to the office the
tone is changing back and a new
cheerfully dependent press is in the air
over the past few months beginning with
the parliamentary elections Kremlin
allies have taken steps designed to warn
outlets against uncensored coverage of
dissent in december russian tycoon
alisher usmanov who's the owner of the
konor sound publishing house and which
produces the prominent business daily
Kommersant was sacked the news of that
was a huge block Kovalsky is an expiry
experienced journalist and one of the
fathers of commerce and critics say that
the magazine coverage of the
parliamentary election was surely the
reason for the sacking a week after the
vote most of the magnens coverage was
devoted to the alleged fraud that led to
the public outrage and protests
unprecedented in Russia in the past
decade the formal reason though which
was given for heading the magazine was
the use of unacceptable coarse language
the thing is the magazine had published
the photo of a ballot with a handwritten
insult against Putin across it the
garment said this is an acceptable it
hinges on hooliganism and Kowalski there
was a particular reason to sac possible
other prominent media outlets have also
been subjected to official intimidation
and februari Gazprom media which holds
the controlling shares in a commissary
radio demanded a premature shuffling of
the radio board the radios board of
directors and the removal of two of the
off its most prominent members I like
saving adicto of the broadcaster's chief
editor and his deputy Vadim infer follow
me f were excluded from the board to the
board shuffle followed a public scolding
of the broadcaster's editorial line by
Vladimir Putin himself during a January
18 meeting with chief editors of the
Russian of leading russian news outlets
putin adapt meeting accused a hamas v of
serving us interest and said that the
station was sneering him non-stop from
dusk till dawn well Gazprom took notice
and the board was shuffled
the next attack against the media took
place februari 16th when Russia's
Prosecutor General's Office launched an
investigation against the dasht
television station and it was that that
prosecution was that investigation was
launched on the claim by you know of a
united russia NP by the name of Robert
Schlegel to accuse the broadcaster of
accepting foreign money for being a
mouthpiece for the December protesters
and another another case love but now's
not least the independent newspaper
Novaya Gazeta was obstructed by heaven
ahead of the presidential vote in
February agents from the interior
ministry the FSB and more than 100
auditors descended on the businesses of
the newspapers major shareholder
Alexander Lebedev for an alleged plug
plant tax audit well the thing is that
the business of Alexander leviton had
just over had just been subjected to
such an audit a few months back and
there was a 500-page report that showed
absolutely no breach of the law so of
course the question is why at this time
why another audit the auditors were
interested in the profit that Labrador
uses used for his humanitarian and media
organizations including Novaya Gazeta
which is known for its relentless
criticism of the footing government
policies leviton's personal accounts are
currently frozen of course this affect
the work of noah gazeta
so as Russia is entering a third term of
put his rule the international community
must pay close attention to his
treatment of media and to stand up for
journalists in Russia every time they
are attacked her ass censored and
obstructed failure to do so will result
in issues that are important not just
for Russia but only for the
international community being
underreported or completely uncovered
and that is a danger because a closed
society society is a society that is not
a good international partner Thank You
Nina and thank you in particular I think
for reminding us that we are on the one
hand witnessing big and frightening
political change but also amid great
technological change and change in media
and how it works and what in its the
impact on the practice of journalism
that was really the collision of those
changes along with the growing climate
of fear and intimidation in a community
Luke you had that again of that go over
there you've had the interesting
experience of having ostensibly all the
freedoms of a Western correspondent and
yet practicing journalism amid the
tightening closing atmosphere that that
buena Nina had been talking about and
sure it should led you in interesting
places yeah thank you very much right if
I could be here thank you thank you
Bruce I was asked to put my comments in
a historical context and so I was I was
totting it up i'm actually the eighth
Moscow correspondent for the British
newspaper The Guardian since the
Bolshevik Revolution I come around I
come in at number eight and actually if
i look at my predecessors they're pretty
distinguished bunch the first one was
arthur ransome it was better known for
his short stories for children but
ransom sort of shared a flat with carl
Radek from the Politburo he played chess
with Lenin
in the evenings and he had a passionate
affair with leon trotsky 'he's secretary
who he likes so much he actually married
her and carted her off back to England
after his assignment and there was then
an interregnum but the second Guardian
correspondent bad then of course it was
them it was the Manchester Guardian was
someone called Malcolm Muggeridge who
you may or may not have heard of but
Margaret lived in Moscow in 1932 in 1933
and and it was interesting just
reflecting on my own unhappy stint as a
correspondent which culminated with my
expulsion from Moscow last year by the
Kremlin I thought of a lot of that
Muggeridge because Muggeridge picked
pitched up in the kind of dark years of
the 1930s and and he might have been
expected to give essentially a kind of
sympathetic account of that the brave
new world being constructed by the
Soviets but instead he was kind of
instantly appalled by what he found sort
of tyranny censorship brutality poverty
hypocrisy and what Aundre ye'd writing
after the war in my favorite collection
of essays by disillusion x communists
the god that failed called the extent of
the bluff and some he was he was
particularly excoriating about his
fellow correspondence in moscow at the
time him he thought had kind of colluded
in this deceit by sending either
ignoring what was going on or sending
even sending propagandistic dispatches
back to Moscow and he himself reported
on the famines in Ukraine and the
caucuses and actually managed to do some
some real journalism and he wrote a
terrific book afterwards it's a
satirical novel called winter in Moscow
published in 1934 and it's it's a sort
of thinly disguised attack on some of
the fellow travelers who were there with
him in particular William durante the
pulitzer-winning correspondent for for
the New York Times and the
quintessential useful idiot who who
basically filed these sort of prop a
ansa Stalin and was actually
instrumental in persuading Roosevelt to
recognize the Soviet regime in the 1930s
and just in the preface to winter is in
Moscow
Muggeridge writes about the position of
foreign journalists in Russia he
describes news from Russia as a joke and
he talks about stiff censorship of
course but he says it's not generally
known that foreign journalists in Moscow
work under the perpetual threat of
losing their visas and therefore their
jobs now the extraordinary thing is that
when I arrived 75 years after muggeridge
to a certain extent the system that he
described is still operational and that
we can talk about the taboos the face
jealous both Russian and foreign in the
panel but just very briefly I think
there are three of them there are three
things which get you kind of sent off in
this sort of Kremlin media world one of
them is writing about corruption not not
in not in the way that Dmitry Medvedev
does it is this kind of tough abstract
problem but in connection with named
senior figures inside the Russian
administration in particular Vladimir
Putin whose personal fortune everyone
knows about but you're not allowed to
talk about that's 12 is the FSB that
Russia's all-powerful murky Counter
Intelligence Agency run up until 1999
buy it by 1 v.v Putin and three is Rams
and cadeira off it's extremely dangerous
to write about him and to write
critically about him and he's another
absolute taboo so when I arrived in
Moscow arrived in January 2007 with my
wife and my two small children and
really we talked about this a little bit
this morning but but how it felt for me
as a correspondent within months of my
arrival we were really kind of plunged
unwittingly into this sort of badly
scripted cold war drama and now what
happened in brief is this to my
colleagues in London did an interview
with Boris Berezovsky in which you know
a man sort of prone to ranting really
and to self aggrandizement and he told
my colleagues in London that he was
plotting nothing less than a than a
revolution against Vladimir Putin and my
job was to merely phone Dmitry Peskov
Putin's fest folks Minh and asking for a
quick quote which I did and
so so the following day my name is on
the front page guardian story I am
plotting Russian Revolution says Boris
Berezovsky by two guys and Luke Harding
in Moscow and really after this story
which I think a more relaxed regime
would have sort of dismisses the
rantings of a kind of paranoid exile
that the sky sort of fell on my head and
the FSB took a very keen interest in me
now what I've had word creative from
from junior and nina and it certainly
was very creative what happened I mean
for a start there was a summons I was
summoned by the FSB to an interview at
lefort of a prison they found out my
office and said that you know I should
come along I said I don't want to they
said you have no choice bring a lawyer
so I said three weeks after this rather
silly article was published I found
myself outside and fought over which for
those of you who don't know it is the
rather ominous billing with yellow drab
spiraling reservoir and a place where
Jenna's not normally admitted and I came
into the waiting room which was a little
bit smaller than the room here it didn't
have the view but also more than that
there were no tables and chairs it was
entirely empty that's so so that the
kind of intimidation was beginning if
you like it was a silver mirror on the
right hand side and so the person there
I could see me but I couldn't see them
and this I saw a little hairy hands the
FSB's hairy hand appeared officers hand
took my passport and phone and that was
it and then we perceive that the others
kind of gloomy stairwell and in the
court there was a lift going down to the
prison where hella costs key live in
yenko whatever else was kept with bars
on it and in the stairwell were these
KGB cameras which should have followed a
subject as we were going along and we
got to room 306 and inside it was was
the FSB major who'd summoned me major AV
cuz mean and the interrogation what was
pointless and and was merely there to
kind of it was a sort of pro forma
frightening I think but what the thing I
remember most vividly was that there was
at a
with fizzy mineral water and glasses on
it and the glasses had initials on them
and the initials were checker AAG poo
curr get bit FS babe okay and it was
clear that I was a relatively novice
correspondent at that point communism
had you know the Soviet empire collapsed
due decades earlier but it was clear
that the FSB saw itself as part of this
you know conspiratorial check 'used des
in ski tradition and that you know the
original checker role of defending the
state and smiting its enemies had
continued and not only that but I had
apparently provisionally been identified
as one of those energies enemies who
needed smiting and then affordable was
the kind of at the obvious bid the bit
above the surface but in addition to
that what the FSB did to me over a
period of almost four years was break
repeatedly into my into my flat where I
live with my wife on my two small
children and it was anyone I got my
hands on the WikiLeaks cables at the end
of 2010 when I discovered that indeed
you must affirm that suffer from this
thing as well and not not only that they
came up for a they had a posh word for
it they call them house intrusions
rather than break-ins and John Burrell
who was the ambassador when I was there
complained about how these house
intrusions were sort of spiking in the
second Putin term and were really making
making the lives of his diplomats and
their spouses pretty miserable and I
mean you can explain why I mean you can
talk about I mean these cables attempt
to explain why the FSB do this they took
about paranoia about an orange
revolution they took about the
xenophobic Soviet worldview of the
people who run Russia's parishes and so
on but whatever the reason I I found
these break-ins to be rather unpleasant
and that the methodology of harassment
was this that the this team of agents
would come in obviously when you were
not there and they wouldn't steal your
television like an honest burglar would
or your video collection or your DVDs or
your laptop or anything like that what
they would do is they would leave little
demonstrative clues that they've been
there so the first time it happened I
came in to discover that
the bedroom which we double locked of my
son's bedroom we lived on the 10th floor
the winner had been opened with the
implication that you might just meet
with Max n'ton and fall out into the
Devore below which would have been
deadly that then had an alarm clock that
night which went off for ten in the
morning which we hadn't said we moved to
her to a lovely dacha in Passy liquid
logic off in a so-called artist village
in Moscow where we had a burglar alarm
yippee but we came back one day to
discover that every single battery from
the burglar alarm had been removed and
at that point we gave up on the Bergeron
up at his prints and then in addition to
their kind of that the spooky break-ins
my email was hacked repeatedly there
were break-ins in my office the phone
was left I've coming in the morning to
discover the phone demonstrative Lee off
the hook in front of my laptop I had
physical surveillance I had unpromising
pimply young men in leather jackets who
would follow me into cafes and
restaurants and kind of like that which
was kind of comic at a bit silly and I
tried an experiment at one point I am
because whenever I said talked about
sensitive issues my phone would be cut
so instead of using the word Berezovsky
I tried using the web banana you know
banana is written asst and amazingly
this worked but I could have a phone
call without the line being cut and the
most kind of extraordinary aspect of
this kind of KGB play but was I came
back one day to discover a book or
orange book in Russian along all the
kind of middle class English novels on
sex and relationships and it had been
bookmarked to page 110 and so I open
page 110 to discover advice on orgasms
how long has an orgasm properly and I
was basically I mean it was just a
surreal moment I was thinking you know
is this a problem frequency technique
are they watching in fact I substance
covered they were watch watching that we
had audio video the whole lot and what's
interesting about this harassment is
that it's these are the techniques that
Vladimir Putin learnt from the KGB at
spy school which were also deployed by
the Stars II
1970s and 80s against dissidents against
members of church groups and so on and
that here they are being wheeled out
when I'm not talking about some dim and
distant era I'm talking about up until
two thousand eleven when I was keytab
many other foreign correspondents
journalists Russian journalist human
rights activists they know about this
because it happens to them too and just
to wrap up thinking of Muggeridge again
you know writing in the early 1930s
about the perpetual threat to
correspondence of losing their visas and
therefore their jobs it turns out it's
still a reality and just my personal
story was that I was summoned back in
late 2010 to look at the WikiLeaks
cables which the Guardian had together
with from from our Australian friend
who's now our ex friend mr. Julian
Assange don't do business with him
unless you absolutely have to he's a
tricky guide to work with but anyway um
I was in the Guardian sort of secret
bunker on the fourth floor in London of
office in Kings Cross the new york times
were looking at lemoore we're all
playing for these cables on on Russia
which were fascinating because
essentially that they they showed that
privately the US State Department had
the same despairing view of Russia that
our idea that i'd accumulated over four
years they're kind of regarded as a kind
of brutal kleptocracy which is
essentially what it is and so I'm
sitting there this overheated room and
the phone rings and it's oleg vici loaf
from from the the mead from the russian
from history press department saying
that i have to come in for an urgent
meeting he won't tell me what it's about
but two weeks later i flew back to
Moscow I went to the mead building which
is on staria just off start stereo birds
and he began our encounter by talking
about the weather how about how how warm
it was in Moscow when it should have
been snowing and I just I just realized
oh no this isn't good he's talking about
the weather and it turned out to be
worse than I'd imagined after 20 minutes
he basically said that mead were not
renewing my visa and I had to get out of
Russia by Christmas this was in November
and so so then we tried to plan the sea
the British government got involved and
william hague got involved other serious
foreign minister and after some
negotiations the me degree that I could
stay in Moscow until May it may have
last year may 2011 so that our kids
could finish their school and so I then
wrote a book on Wikileaks and my wife
and children were back in Moscow then
febri of last year almost exactly a year
ago I flew back to dominate over airport
I made it as far as passport control I
handed over my passport to a young woman
from the federal Border Agency who typed
in my details and then went like this
there's a complete double Tech had of my
passport someone else and this official
then disappeared I texted the press
secretary from the British Embassy
saying i'm i'm at da madeira airports my
passports been take away taking away
doesn't look too good and he texted back
and said he he he they're probably just
messing with you he was subsequently
promoted as now in Washington and um and
then the official came out and he said
he listened when he said Daniel vows
rocio the critter you know so what for
you Russia is closed and I said pochemu
uh you know why he said yeah he's no
fish turtles killing you know I don't
know why did he do something I said yet
can achieve on his deal and that was
basically it I was courted against the
flow of traffic back to the plane I just
flown in on I was taken to a deportation
zone I was shown into a cell it would
locked in there was a kind of lost world
of Central Asians tragic guys a woman
from Congo who'd been there many days
awake awaiting deportation and I was
like the kind of alien visitor what why
was this prosperous scruffy you know
European being deported you know answer
that they could understand it and I
couldn't understand it either and just
finally on on the plane I got my
passport back with a big blue stamp
saying a null as my visa which was of
course valid and my phone rang and it
was Adam roughage at the Guardians
editor-in-chief and I thought that he
was going to say
that the British government has sorted
this out this was all a misunderstanding
or perhaps that the SAS were going to
come and rescue me or something and Alan
just said he's a real aconnick guy and
he just said they really don't like you
do they and I said no Alan they really
don't the door shut and that was
basically it that was the end of my four
year career as the curtains Moscow
correspondent so I mean I think just to
wrap up that what we're seeing here is
that we're seeing these techniques which
which a time on a KGB techniques they've
been employed over a long period of time
including against you mr. American
journalists who covered the Moscow beat
in the 60s and 70s and even in the globe
which off period by being wheeled out
again and it's clear why it's clear that
the idea is to send a sort of message to
other people and it's to basically say
that if you if you break the rules these
informal rules of censorship then nasty
things will happen to you but but how
nasty you don't know so I think it's I
think it's I think the situation with
the girls press freedom is extremely
dispiriting and I mean they're out there
are two rules we can talk about in a way
I'm in airway try to aggrandize my story
because the heroes of this story are not
foreign journalists who enjoy a degree
of protection they're Russian
journalists especially Russian Jonas in
the province who are wonderfully brave
wonderfully courageous vulnerable to
official abuses and I think we should
all salute them thank you look the
great American reporter George cell dis
who was one of the first American
journalists interview Lennon had a motto
whose motto was tell the truth and run
and I think um I'm gonna throw out one
question to all you and then maybe we
can make it a conversation for the next
hour I want to tease out one thing which
is yes this the the this heavy
authoritarian hand is clearly present
but if as Luke said this is a highly the
highly evolved descendant of the old KGB
and its predecessors its encountering a
world that is in rapid transformation
and we saw with the Arab Spring how old
mechanisms of authoritarianism don't
work as well anymore maybe Nina starting
with you because I know you pay a lot of
attention to this but for any of you how
is the the decentralized world of social
media and blogs that's so difficult to
control playing into this closing of
press freedom horizons that we see now
well if you have to we're talking about
Russia here and Russia still is a very
television dominated society
surely enough in the urban centers
social media are a very prevalent young
people are constantly blogging there on
social networks young and not so young
people are doing that in the in the non
provincial area but in the Russia's
province internet is still a luxury and
to have a personal computer it's still
the exception rather than the rule so
the government doesn't have the need to
yet control heavy handedly those new
kinds of media they're not paying as
close attention because the internet
story the story on the blog does not yet
have the overwhelming power to turn a
story into political events we're
starting to see the slowly moving change
to the other side and the authorities
are starting to pay more attention and
one of those cases I just mentioned the
investigation that was launched against
the independent online television
channel dasht is a good example that the
Kremlin is starting to pay attention to
these new kinds of media and so we have
to to be vigilant again
to not pay attention to just what
happens in Moscow but also to look at
what happens to the lone lager in
Siberia and to to react when local
authorities descend on those soul
figures freelancers internet journalists
bloggers because who will be seeing more
and more cases for sure this is where
we're moving towards dunno how do you
see these issues playing together well
I'm apart from the issues that Nina
mentioned and of course this is the
conference dedicated to destroy car and
Russia again I would bring in to picture
the effect that Russia and everything
that's happening in Russia will have on
the former Soviet Union countries and
this is already visible this is already
very present because the attempts to
block certain websites to filter
internet increasing comparing just to
the last year and comparing to the
latest developments in Russia is having
tremendous effect to this part of the
world internet is such comparing to
these countries in Russia is in a way
considered partly free why I do not have
answer to this but I was present in
Douma last September when put in
actually talking to the MP said modern
countries do not block intimate modern
countries do not restrict intimate we
are never going to do this so what
happened to that I don't know but I'm
constantly using it when I talk to the
authorities in order to point out the
importance of this of course we are all
aware of the fact that medida was also
very vocal on this but what does it mean
in
real world and in some hidden parts of
the Russia or not to mention countries
of the former Soviet Union is a
different story the population that is
now under tremendous attack the proud
from journalists and you know people
that are really engaging in professional
journalism every day is a group of
social media activists bloggers because
of the tools they are using because of
the means they are using and because the
information travels faster than ever so
the governments are trying to fix it by
blocking it by putting these people
behind the bars and also what we have to
be aware of that the problem is dealt
with in a way that their dubious
fabricated charges pressed against these
people so if you have freedom activist
if you have institutions fighting for
free expression going to the authorities
and asking them to release these people
you hear the answers and the answer is
they are not there because of their
journalistic activities because of
investigative journalism because of
revealing corruption criminal they are
there because there are terrorists drug
dealers than hooligans so these three
are most used terms if they if they want
to put people behind bars there are also
other means than we are all very much
aware of those but I do not think we are
moving into more rosy situation when it
comes to this and that's why I think
what both Nina and Luke were saying that
these people far away so not only famous
journal is not only the ones that we all
know about need protection and they need
understanding that there is some one
outside taking care of them in a way of
it as much as we can but it's not an
easy task look yeah I mean I just want
to say that that that there's one thing
we've missed here which is the fact that
that the Kremlin employs a kind of vast
army of bloggers to for every kind of
liberal bloggers you have you know
pasting a photo of Novalis miling a
triumph you have you have you know five
Kremlin bloggers saying that he's a CIA
spy and and really I think that we need
to be realistic about this regime I mean
it sure it's it's it's a repressive
regime but it's not stupid it's kind of
adaptive its postmodern what we're not
talking about a sad Syria or Gaddafi's
Libya what we're talking about a kind of
socially engaged the government and and
these bloggers I mean they're
unbelievably tenacious and that
obviously primarily they blog in Russian
websites livejournal and so on but they
also absolutely spill over into the
international arena I mean the Guardian
whenever there's any article on Russia
whether commenting facility eighty
percent of the comments are pro-putin
which is curious given our kind of
progressive movie eating kind of you
know readership normally and of course
they're all their Kremlin trolls I mean
they're paid to do this but they're
incredibly active they've got very good
software so as soon as any Russia piece
pings up the first five comments will be
will be essentially pro-russian
government and they the idea is to kind
of discredit just discredit that the
critical of government so I've had an
enormous amount of kind of abuse I've
been described as a Korean spy British
spy CIA spy well which all just true
tell us here or here forever the truth
I've been described as the apotheosis of
bastard Western journalism and in
addition that they also these guys also
take to Twitter I currently have 24
Twitter clones I got my first clone last
summer and I faxed San Francisco and I
put a stake through his heart but then
he came back from the dead and he
brought his friends with him
I'm Luke Harding 1968 and there are now
Luke Harding 1960 all the way through
cutting 1984 and that they are that's
that they've got my photo and my bio and
they are they are furiously tweeting
dmitry medvedev press releases from the
Kremlin and at one point my my face
became the editors face it's currently
my face again and the idea is so
confusion to to discredit your enemy
enemies and so on and they are
relentless and I have to say it is kind
of demoralizing these techniques work so
that there's a lot of contestation I
mean obviously there are old-school
techniques of Australian was saying of
imprisoning bloggers but there's also
these new-school techniques of having an
army of trolls cyber trolls whom you
send out due to do battle in New York
Times the garden every morning and you
literally club over the head or what not
literally figuratively club over the
head anybody who disagrees with you well
and you know it strikes me that this
kind of not only the trolls but the
increasingly sophisticated pro-kremlin
media like Russia today she which your
pal Julian Assange yeah I mean I was
unbelievable I mrs. Wright know anyone
believe that genius I was waiting for
Russia today I mean who break that story
well it forced me to ask another
question before I turn it over to the
mic which is how are the genuine voices
of accountability journalism getting her
to mid this den I mean Nina you talked
about the importance of TV and Russia
today externally is now the sort of soft
face of the Kremlin there's you know the
social media what how are legitimate
authentic accountability journalists
washed all journalists managing to get
hurt at all well I mean I just want very
brief follow-up to what look what
describing this is not typical just for
Russia it's a technique that's adopted
by
any author Rotarians I see in the
Eurasian region we just are now dealing
with a very precarious case in
Azerbaijan where one of the leading
investigative journalists of that
country is being smeared online using
again this new new way of disseminating
information what we what we think it is
really government government harassment
his channel through the new media and
and the web is now turned this into a
weapon against this journalist who is
conducting importance investigative
reporting on government corruption
instead the attention is now forcibly
brought to her personal life she's being
smeared she's being defamed she's being
embarrassed publicly and it's happening
also in a in a dangerous environment
because Azerbaijan is a conservative
society where there there are hate
crimes and a journalist I any person
could get into trouble female
journalists could get in trouble with a
lot of haters for the reason of having a
personal life and this is what's
happening to this this one journalist
right now it's a nasty technique it's
the more we are learning on the case
it's their obvious that there is
government involvement in the case
because it was not just this mere
campaign online it was followed up with
articles in the state newspapers that
was smearing against her and so the the
new authoritarian regimes
very fast learners they're using a
combination of old-style censorship
techniques and combining them
effectively was the new type of newly
created methods of censoring and
smearing their physical existence is in
danger in Azerbaijan and she's standing
up to this degree this government a
green right now what we need to do
collectively is give platforms to
journalists like her to get to follow up
on the stories that they cover and
amplify their voices this is the best
kind of protection that they can get
from us any thoughts on this yeah it's
it's a you know of course it's extremely
important that when people are putting
the situation like this and they are
known for being the fierceness you know
courageous journalists that are you know
no matter what is happening to them no
matter about the threat to them and
their families they are continuous but
it's not an easy thing it is also not an
easy thing for for us that are trying to
help for you know in a different ways
NGOs and institutions that are actually
trying to change something because in a
way in the society nothing is changing
we are helping short-term people that
are in trouble short-term successes in a
way visible on a daily basis people are
released from prison people are allowed
to continue working there are also cases
where people are released from prison
and then afterwards there is a band of
several years to perform their job as
journalists I mean that there are
hundreds of sophisticated and
unsophisticated ways of shutting someone
of you know continuing to talk about
issues that are problematic sensitive
and pay or painful in the society but
what I see also as
huge problem is the way that you know
all these things being public and trying
to help individuals in a way we are not
here i'm not talking about civil society
i'm not talking about ngos i'm talking
about international organizations here
failing to change something in the
regime's they have tools to address
these issues in the societies they have
tools to say you are not complying with
the commitments that you voluntarily
agreed upon that all these countries
agree that they will comply with article
19 you know European Convention of Human
Rights you know OIC commitments they are
failing to do so I mean they are greatly
failing to do so countries are not
complying with the rulings of the
european court of human rights in
relation to generals activities in
turkey at the moment we have according
to the OSC data hundred and three
journalists in prison the most you know
the biggest number in the world several
were released last week but the one is
again you know facing charges because of
his statements when he left the prison
so you know we are in a vicious circle
in in trying to help but as I think that
investigative journalism and journalism
is such free free speech so not just all
connected with the with journalism free
speech is under threat worldwide but you
know that's more philosophical question
and the statement that we cannot solve
at this particular event but the case is
that we are seeing even if you do this
job all the time every single day I'm
stunned and shocked to see which ways
and mechanisms are used in order to
silence this critical voices let's do
some questions from the room now and a
reminder that you should a line up at
the mic behind Cathy who gets the
privilege of the first question
we are on the record being videotaped so
if you don't want to be on the record or
be videotaped don't ask a question okay
and to identify yourself so just in case
anybody I can figure out this is
Kathleen Epona she again uh you look you
were very good about historical
perspective I want to shorten of course
you know talk a little and you know
Christina you also gave some historical
perspective but um I wanted to push that
a little bit and I've been having
trouble trying to figure out how to
formulate this question but we we have a
nice mix of of the issue of the
foreigner in Russia and the Russian in
Russia or or the Soviet citizen or the
larger Russian Imperial center whatever
we want to call it here is one part of
the question the other part is the issue
the use of tactics that are remarkably
similar on to those as you pointed out
that we used in the Soviet period even
correcting for technology I mean they're
really varied smear campaigns break-ins
all of them taken being taken till
affordable for a little chat with your
KGB person all of this stuff but it was
used against dissidents not against
journalists you didn't need those
tactics against Russian journalists or
was used against inconvenient foreigners
including journalists um you know so
that's one difference that that that's
that I'm not sure I know what to make up
I mean in other words that the synergy
between foreign and Russian journalists
has somehow changed or between the
people who are oppositionists have
changed journalists were not
opposition's in the Soviet period the
distance were someone else and they used
western journalists arm and i'm so i'm
not sure if you want to comment on that
but I'd also i mean this may be a false
generalization but i'll try it out
anyway well it seems to be that most of
the journalists before what the foreign
journalists who were kicked out in the
course of the Soviet period it was in
the in the space of a larger political
context and it wasn't necessarily I mean
that could have been a particularly
inconvenient foreign journalists but it
also could have been a particularly bad
moment in the relationship between the
Soviet Union and Britain or the United
States and it was particularly good
moment to kick someone out and make a
statement do you think there's an
element of that and what happens to you
I mean it was a particularly bad moment
and British Russian relations and did
that has something to do with it okay
sorry that's sort of everybody last
button sure when you answer okay right
um just right before yeah i mean i
arrived at the single worst moment for a
British correspondents turn up in Moscow
it's just three months after Alexander
Litvinenko and had his famous cup of tea
you know which was clearly a bad moment
but I mean obviously the geopolitics is
is important I mean it's a friend of
mine for watching place was saying that
you know the u.s. is that the 800-pound
gorilla in the room and I think Britain
is probably the small excitable monkey
in a way annoy you know you kicked the
monkey to annoy the gorilla right I mean
that there's a degree of that I think
that that that if you if you expel the
corresponding from New York Times that's
like kind of declaring war on the Obama
administration was that the British are
kind of irritating and basically Putin
is never the prop the problem with Putin
is that he's never forgiven tony blair
for not extraditing boris berezovsky
back in 2003 when he had his asylum
application this is actually the
beginning of this whole anglo-russian
saga but his Putin thought that Blair
could have picked up the phone to the
judge and told him what to do but he
didn't because he was arrogance and
patronizing and so on and I think are
the root of a lot of this treatment of
all bad treatment of journalists both
Russian and Western particularly Western
is is mirror thinking that basically you
know if you're in Putin universe
journalists are a priori Stickley there
they are all basically spies and and
what was so ridiculous is I was
basically treated for four years like
James Bond you know where people for you
know I don't have a car I took my kids
to school on the 23 metro I'm really
scruffy most of the time you know I
don't like my teeny I mean that the
whole thing was ludicrous but but that
what you can't stress enough is is how
these people by which I mean that the
people at the top of the Kremlin live in
their own fantasy world their own
informational reality in which Putin can
stand that quite seriously and cry and
say his enemies are all western Stooges
and genuinely believe it there's no you
know there's no reason for that but
that's because he's in his own universe
and I think an increasingly kind of
dangerous universe and I think that
that's that that's the heart of it is
this this and we're thinking that
basically in Savior days Russian
journalist posted aboard juni or concern
were spies but the idea that I could
just be a regular journalist trying to
portray Russia realistically and to
write about corruption never crosses
their might I mean I'm going to add a
thought on this too which is that I also
see what happened to Luke and what has
happened to many Russian journalists in
the last couple years as the Russian
expression of something we're seeing
worldwide there was a time when even
very bad regimes needed journalists on
some needed media on some level needed
foreign correspondence or needed
independent TV or whatever to credibly
communicate their message bad guys
needed journalists you could go into a
war zone wearing big letters saying
press and you know in Northern Ireland
the IRA needed journalists as much as
the the British government did that has
really changed with the advent of of the
internet on YouTube and so on and
increasingly both state actors and
non-state actors see journalists
principally as a mechanism for
communicating fear and I certainly would
say that in in your case and even more
so in the case is that Nina deals with
all the time the intent is not just to
punish a single journalist but to spread
fear throughout the community of
journalists in a particular way that
would be my interpretation
I think the problem it really comes back
to mentality the Russian and
administration of today may have evolved
in sophistication and in understanding
of the of the outside world in ways but
in its regards of the media it really
has not changed that much from how it
used to view the media during the Soviet
time and that's the reason why we didn't
see those kind of tactics against
journalists we saw them against distance
again book authors but not against the
media because the press was the that the
tool of the government and that's what
the Russian administration of today
wants to keep the the media and wants to
domesticate the media continues to
strive for that in fact there was saying
that that there was an interview with
putting gave to I think it was a French
journalist during his first term he said
something like you know the press like
Authority like a man should always try
and the price like a woman should always
resist and that's how he continues to
see where his relationship with the
press one of contradiction and
resistance doing it just I think we
should also not forget that this is not
only Russian authorities and foreign
journalists we also have to keep in mind
that there is a huge number of Russian
journalists there that is trying to
change things in their societies and
there are seen or also as the enemies
and this is changing we
heard needa mentioned so many cases that
were recently happening in Russia and
there are now really the ones that need
support and attention from the outside
world because i think you know it's very
easy for the administration to attack
and to continue seeing look as a James
Bond no I I'm not saying it no no but
you also said a different CIA was
something else as well and I still
didn't figure out what exactly but
anyway I do think that certain papers
and individuals are also example for for
the rest of the world when it comes to
being professional courageous and you
know important voice of the society and
we'll be hearing tomorrow from several
colleagues in the rush of press corps on
these issues sir this is just an
observation just a reminder to identify
yourself oh my name is Jack con this is
just an observation what an incredible
of let me think a moment how unfortunate
it is that Steven Cohen had to leave
before this panel what an incredible
back-and-forth dialogue we could have
had on the infrastructure of Putin's
repression any of you who are in the
room for steves well we were it was
plenty of light so I yes people yeah
okay in 1942 roberto rossellini made a
movie under under a fascist regime about
russian troops fighting member dawn and
what was conspicuous about it was the
virtual total absence of any propaganda
the russian civilians were treated with
humanity and sympathy that's Italy at
the same time the Germans had
pagando ministry undergo burst in which
any german journalist at the time would
have had no doubt whatsoever as to what
was permitted and what wasn't course
this is German go English kite and
Italian what the Germans Caramba I
through different cultures now in Russia
was there any bureaucratic structure
behind censorship wasn't tell was it all
arbitrary willful and capricious or was
there a censorship bureau that had
periodic meetings producing specific
guidelines for all the journalists
foreign and domestic as to what was
permitted and what wasn't or did the
journalists operate I'm a kind of
self-censorship because who knows when
they could be attacked anyone carried
over can I just briefly I mean I mean
that the problem the problem for me is
it cannot as a systemic respond a bit
but by the time I turned up in the sort
of i was going to say the late Putin
period but it could be the early Putin
period let's say you know 2007 no one
you were the rules were I think the
rules work here in Soviet times I mean
we you knew it was a bad idea to write
about you know Putin's fortune you knew
it was bad idea to travel in the North
Caucasus and uni was bad to write about
spider and season live in the end code
but but but precisely where those
borders were they were new and that is
that is that is the problem and of
course that the whole genius of this is
is that people self-censor you know
people self-censor because they're not
sure where the boundaries are and then
and then periodically every so often you
kick out a correspondent like me and all
I can say is that on a personal level I
never knew what the what the worst thing
was that they would do to me I thought
it was extremely unlikely i'd get beaten
up or shot because that that you know
that you know those are the rules for
Western journalists all I mean that's
awful but that's true and the
straightening was when I was being
locked in the cell at Dom Dover airport
about fly back and re-watch the social
network for the second time I had this
wonderful moment of catharsis because I
thought okay they're going to lie about
me they're going to
yeah and that's the West I would just
like to add a question of
self-censorship that it's important to
remember particularly in Russia but
elsewhere as well that self censorship
is not only a matter of what story am I
not going to report today
self-censorship also occurs for
journalists who are experienced great
fear who are suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder or
depression or other psychological
consequences of chronic threat and
stress a journalist who is silenced by
that kind of distress who's no longer
able to work effectively is censored as
effectively as if she or or he simply
said I'm not going to do stories XY and
Z and I think that's a very big part of
what we have seen particularly with
investigative or watchdog journalists in
Russia kinds of cases that Nina deals
with so yes yes and again remember to
give your name please for my name is dr.
Mildred poner my president have seen
them I've never eat any international
inc and I've worked in the Russian Far
East as well as other parts of the
former Soviet Union my question is
Benina specifically I thought was very
what we've all been interesting she
mentioned the fact we when we're talking
about the internet we are talking about
Moscow and st. Petersburg we don't
necessarily talk about other parts of
the world now I guess I agree with that
but I would like to point out something
I saw that if it was absolutely
extraordinary and see when were talking
about Russia we practically never talk
about anything that's that extraordinary
I've made a film called mother's want an
abandoned children of Eastern Europe and
when I was in various parts of russian
far east in Siberia I came across a what
looked like a barn which was run an
internet barn which was run by
orphans and we all know what the orphan
situation is like in that part of the
world these kids were so empowered they
were actually earning money they were so
positive they were in this little
backwater town they had learned the
internet and they were getting educated
so my question is has anyone ever seen
anything like that anyplace else in
Russia because I thought it was
absolutely extraordinary as I learned
there after that the computers were
actually donated by an American and I
used them they were very slow but still
they were absolutely incredible so
that's my question anybody in the room
any place of the former Soviet Union
ever see orphans who were given a
meaningful test they were also helped
build the barn they lived in the barn
they were extraordinary thank you very
much anyone know that's that's a great
example and I think that there are
projects and not just in Russia but in
in other countries of the former Soviet
bloc where where people are trying to
organize themselves they're trying to
educate to have professional workshops
and trainings and initiatives well how
old were they
so yes my name is Marian good Eva I am
an exchange student here in Colombia
from Moscow State University of the
Faculty of journalism so my hellmann's
the University of was is the main
institution which prepares Russian
journalists and professors at my home
University always treated investigative
journalism is the most prestigious one
and took yuri chaika chicken and anna
politkovskaya role models for students
and students actually really respect and
investigative journalism and all my
classmates took part in all protest and
wrote about it and as well as there was
a huge scandal in November when Mitra
Mitra chief came to moscow state
university in the Faculty of journalism
and so he spoke to his supporters and no
students from faculty live alone so and
there was a huge scandal and they showed
the placate it was like my classmates
who showed the placate with the
questions like why are you in Twitter
and the color coughs keys in the jail or
why the why Cashin was beaten and
something like this so and well a lot of
people actually after this all the
sections they said that it's just like a
stupid showing golf and that
investigative journalism is not so
popular I she does it is dying so I just
wonder how do you think is the
investigative journalism in Moscow I
mean in Russia is still popular and
attractive young generation of
journalists and so yeah and not don't
they aren't they afraid of that well
being investigative journalist but I
think that's a question that you should
answer yourself first life yeah before
are you are you the visp student at bar
nerd um could I just announce something
because because this is the first
student in an exchange with Bernhard
college and the Moscow University
school of journalism which gone ongoing
project and it's very nice that you're
here today I think it's a new initiative
this gonna be going okay so i can just
just I think it will be interesting to
hear from you as a student of journalism
how do you feel about that how you think
that you will go into investigative
journalism in Russia honestly I think
that I'll take part in my marketing
public relations clinic in this field
and so much all my friends date but like
I stopped or know what classmate they're
still like having this dream about
investigative journalist but I hear a
lot of people like this is stupid risto
turn was like this eng total in diamond
yeah but a lot of people are afraid
because yeah i'm a big in eurasia
pachik in their role models everywhere
so all the professor's always talk about
them
and but people like some people are
really afraid of it and they just wonder
like in general like allow me sir and
young generation of journalists is it
like popular wrong now hmm i would just
just say that that I mean there's no in
my head at least there's no big
distinction between kind of being
investigative gems to being a journalist
I mean you know investigative Jones you
don't need it need a beard and smoking
habits and to sit with the whole heat of
news representing basically that's what
journalism is is to investigate what's
going on I mean that's just--that's all
journalism it's not a kind of
subdivision of a bigger journalism and
really is a sort of you know as a
Russian correspondent or as a Western
correspondent your job is just to give
an accurate sort of portrait of what's
out there I think not to have any kind
of special agenda I mean investigative
journalism is merely that you eat you
far less frequently you know instead of
filing every day you work on a longer
project but I think most journalists do
some investigation and some other stuff
but I would just say personally I mean I
do hope you do go into journalism of
marketing the most a while we're
marketing but you know we need get
jealous I think that what what you're
describing is actually how my
observation has been about young the
younger generation in Russia and this is
in Norway criticism finally sort that
journalists you who come out of
journalism school of communications
faculties prefer to go into something
other than the hard news and an
investigative reporting for the many
reasons we just discussed here
investigative journalism terror
journalism if you want to call it is
time consuming it's hard to do it's it's
hard work and it's also imperiled in
Russia anna politkovskaya and you sugar
chicken or burger birth murdered for
their work and so are four other
colleagues of theirs at nova gazeta
where they both wrote it's also very
telling that the
kinds of voices again are teamed up to
work for particular publications they're
not spread out they're not they're not
the mass they're rather they exception
than the rule and that's because there's
no profit in that kind of journalism
there's no there's there's again a lot
of risk in it and young people are
asking themselves is this a dream shall
I go after my dream of becoming this
name and gets the heart stories or
should I make a comfortable living and
perhaps choose something that's similar
to reporting but it would not get me
into trouble and those are questions
that young people are struggling with
today well I mean the simple answer is
yes it is under threat not only in
Russia is a you know where we look
around the world you know this
profession and I in a way disagree but
you just said you're journalist you're
not Nina look if you're journalist you
know of course your investigative
journalist I I also think you know if
you're journalist you are journalists
but then you know there are you know
army of young you know journalists just
after school deciding to go into
entertainment business I'm sure that
isn't good yeah and that is something
completely different for comfortable
life for which other reason because what
you see in the Balkans maybe its effect
of the war or you know after a conflict
you you have different societies you
also have to fight the legacies from the
previous systems and all these things
you know investigative journalist there
are either killed or they work with the
police so you know you you have to
choose you know is that really what you
want to do in your life but then again
the way societies are looking at
journalist is also something that needs
to be changed and that is that is a role
of civil society of all these
organizations
doing it because the dignity of this
profession profession is also under
threat it's not just you know writing
it's also the way these people are seen
by their societies there are seen as the
last group you know there are the ones
that should be in prison they are the
ones that should be should be behind
bars so it's it's also something that we
need to be aware of let me give you a
little bit of a journalism historians
observation of this and I I have to say
first that i've i've had the pleasure of
talking at Moscow State University
journalism faculty a couple of times and
I find your classmates to be fantastic
it's it's a really exciting generation
of students people care about this stuff
look investigative journalism or a lot
of modern journalism really comes from a
collision of innovations innovations in
technology like the invention of the
printing press the invention of
broadcast the invention of the internet
with the political innovation of free
speech and that it is in every society a
political innovation of free speech to
the extent that that has been happening
in Russia that combination of
technological innovation with political
innovation that that I think encourages
people of your generation because you
understand these innovations better than
we do okay anyone on this count I also
think there's one very important
innovation going on in the world of
investigative journalism now that is
different from any other period in
history which is there's a lot of now
international cross-border cooperation
among investigative journalists in
different countries both to work on
stories that involve money and
corruption things that crosses national
boundaries and to publish in ways that
protects local journalists to a certain
extent there are training organizations
across national boundaries there's a
global conference every couple of years
journalists are talking to one another
in new ways and I think that for your
classmates for journalists of your
generation this is going to in Russia
offer a lot of ways of may be breaking
some of the habits of thinking that have
trapped journalism but up until now
could be I don't think it's all doom and
gloom I think there is there are some
real possibilities even in the face of
terrible threats and impunity and that
all the business model problems and so
on yes yes
yeah and this is I mean journalism
generally is becoming more female but at
Moscow State that is really true we
don't know what that means but it has
really important implications yeah hi
Chris Walker at Freedom House I'd like
to thank the panelists for their
insights and observations one thing that
dunya yata which mentioned struck me
which is that multilateral institutions
and bodies that are either observing
Russia and other countries that have
adapted and adopted to modern censorship
levels today haven't really been as
effective as they could be and that's
despite the fact you have many of the
countries in question that had been
discussed actually as members of these
bodies so Council of Europe the OSCE and
so forth kazakhstan was the chairman of
the OSCE tells you a good deal at the
chair grab the chantix there so I my
question is the modern censorship models
that are being applied are being applied
by countries like Russia and Azerbaijan
Kazakhstan and others China is another
example actually much more sophisticated
with using some of the similar
techniques that have been described
herein the Russian context on the one
hand you have this extraordinary
brutality the murders the intimidation
on the other hand you have this
incredible sophistication whereby online
communication isn't fully blocked
there's contestation but there's
participation and that tells you
something in Egypt Osney Mubarak shut
down the internet that didn't work so
well for him and I think some of these
authoritarians have looked at this and
said we need to participate we need to
be in the game but we have to do it on
our terms the other thing I would say
which is critical to this is that none
of these regimes seek to block
everything they seek to block what's
politically consequential they seek to
manage it and it's not simply
journalists but academics scholars who
run afoul of the Kremlin today find
themselves with a stamp and one-way
ticket out there
examples of this have been increasing in
recent years so it's much more
systematic it's very sophisticated but
for some reason the democracies in the
transatlantic community and the
policymakers and the Capitals there
haven't really wrap their minds around
this so I would argue in some ways that
the adapted modern censorship that you
see in Russia and to perhaps similar
degrees in some of the other countries
we've talked about are we it's really
more pernicious than what you saw a
generation ago where it was very
black-and-white it was very clear today
you can meet policymakers and others
kind of shrugged their shoulders and say
look these countries are on their way
there commercially integrating give them
time the problem is you had that
conversation five years ago eight years
ago and hasn't changed that much you
could even argue that the level of
adaptation and the refining of the
models both online and off has improved
so my question is what could we be doing
to help busy policymakers in the most
influential capitals in the West
understand that this is not necessarily
getting better many of these regimes are
figuring out how to insinuate themselves
and manipulate online communication in a
way that defies the more positive
interpretation and the inexorable ax t
of what online communication will mean
I'd be curious to hear from all the
panelists on what they might advise to
have better outcomes no to what to do to
to you know knock on their doors all the
time that what happened I've been trying
to do since I was appointed two years
ago even being part of the organization
opening the eyes pushing them to see the
reality in the countries that are
members for a long time I know I'm
mentioning turkey again the eyes were
you know totally closed because of
political reasons in order to see that
there are hundred people sitting behind
bars kazakhstan was mentioned here being
chairmanship of the OSC so that was one
of
the reasons so all the time you have
something as a badge an important player
you know on all the issues that we are
maybe not interested you know sitting
here but there are also not only these
problems you know of course you know we
have to be pointing out to the
government's to tell them what they need
to do and to give them facts give them
data and numbers of people that are
under threat in the countries that are
members of different organizations but
there are also organizations that having
the tools at their disposal in order to
push countries to comply with their
commitments or obligations and i do not
think they are doing enough it engages
blaming shaming and naming the countries
and that is all the time from ematic for
any political system and no governments
like to be engaged in this and if it is
important strategic partners in
international fora who cares about human
rights you know human rights are always
neglected and not taking care of that is
also you know the fact again I'm
mentioning the bulk and I'm going to
speak at six o'clock more about this
part of of the world and problems there
but I will also mention just another
angle I know it's not very much
connected to the topic but it's actually
affecting investigative journalism and
journals as such it is something related
to what Western countries or democratic
countries are doing and not paying too
much attention to it it is the fact that
they are selling the equipment to these
totalitarian regimes so that's how they
are blocking and filtering and and
silencing people's in their societies
and nobody's doing anything about this
and I just came back from from Toronto
where I had opportunity to speak in a
panel where reduce activist social media
activists from around the world and they
said that's the main problem that's that
they are trying that they are fighting
but surveillance tools and blocking
tools are sold by worldwide known
a great story for any investigative
journalists in the room yeah just Chris
two answers to your question very
quickly what one semi frivolous get
policymakers to buy my book mafia state
coming out in the US and may which is
the kind of unvarnished portrait of
Russia and Putin but more seriously i
think the mainly ridge we have as visas
I mean the Russian elite is a global
elite if you come to London if you walk
around we're stunned and you'll see that
the most expensive flats are owned by
Kremlin bureaucrats not because they're
Steve Jobs or have any kind of great
idea but they're kind of fruits of
corruption and I think this is the one
thing that strikes terror in the heart
of Kremlin bureaucrats is not being out
to get a visa for the US or the UK or
the European Union there are a lot of
tools in the toolbox the proverbial
toolbox of the international
institutions that they can be using and
they're not using to the full capacity
when they have to react to a disobedient
member of these institutions I mean it's
it's absolutely corrected these
countries then we are talking about
their voluntary signatories of all these
international conventions and documents
that that make them bound to a set of
rules and protections of human rights
and press freedom but what happens is
that what works at the the humanitarian
part of the institutions level such as
the OSE media representatives office
within the Aussie structure and what
happens with Thomas hammers Berg's
the Council of Europe commissioner's
office when we talk about the Council of
Europe what what works in the structural
level falls apart of the political level
when decisions have to be collectively
made by member states different members
they just cannot agree and decisions are
based on this the rule of consensus what
we can do and we've been doing that with
the Committee to Protect Journalists we
go to Brussels and we go to Strasbourg
can we talk to we in meetings with the
Council of Europe and with the European
Union we bring up the problem that is
that the this situation creates for us
as human rights and and press freedom
defend the fenders groups not only do we
have to fight the authoritarian states
that are that are pressing on the media
but we also have to fight the resistance
that we just inexplicably are meeting
from institutions that are supposed to
be on our side and so we're supposed to
be fighting the same kind of battle
we're supposed to be on the same side of
the battle and yet we we have to put
effort and attention to lobbying the
very institution that are supposed to be
on the forefront of this on defense of
of journalists rights of press freedom
rights we as an organization come up
with a set of recommendations that we
pull together from the rules and tools
of that proverbial toolbox that
institutions supposed to be using and we
go to them with this recommendation and
ask them to employ them to the best of
their ability in multilateral and
bilateral talks with the government's
we with this state states that we cover
and we offer our cooperation in bringing
up their data in bringing up our
research reporting about human rights
about violations about violations of
press freedom and we were very open to
that kind of cooperation the truth of
the matter is that geopolitical
interests nowadays Trump up the human
rights and human rights take a backseat
I believe that what could be done is for
civil society to get more involved and
the media to get more involved in
putting pressure positive pressure on
the European institutions on the US
government to be more vocal to be more
proactive to be more active in
protecting the right of journalists
enough of civil rights civil activists
human rights defenders because they are
essential for not just for the countries
they function in but also for the
international community that I think is
as good a place as any to end let us
thank our panelists not only for what
you've said today but for the work and
risks you all have taken to advance
press freedom and accountability in
Russia